ومعنا الان هشام زقوت مراسلنا من رفح رفح
التي تبدو كتي يستجير بها كالمستجير من
الرمضاء
بالنار كل من يذهب اليها لا يجد
الماوى
وبالنهايه يلاحق ايضا ضعنا في صوره ما
يجري عندك
هشام بالفعل ليلى الناس تاتي الى رفح على
اساس انها المنطقه الاكثر امنا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يطلب من سكان خانيونس وسكان
قطع غزه بمجمله الذهاب الى رفح والى دير
البلح وهنا يتمركز الناس ويتركز الناس
اكتظاظ سكاني لا غير متصدق لا لا يمكن
تصويره ولا يمكن ذكرت انه يعني عدد السكان
كان 300 ال بالاصل وصار مليون و300 صح هل
هذا الرقم صحيح ما كنت ذكرته تقريبا
بالفعل
بالفعل بحسب بلديه رفح فهم بقوا كانوا
300000 اليوم مليون و300 الف ولك ان
تتخيلي كان هناك 300000 وكانت المدينه
مكتظه الان مليون و300 ال فكيف يمكن ان
تكون رفح رفح اليوم لا يوجد فيها متسع
لقدم جديده لا يوجد فيها ماوي للسكان
الجدد اليوم خلال عمليات القصف المستمره
على مخيم النصيرات مخيم البريج مخيم
المغازي زوايده وقريه المصدر وايضا اجزاء
شرقيه من دير البلح كل هؤلاء يتوجهون اما
الى المناطق الغربيه لدير البلح او
يقتصرون او يذهبون الى رفح الى هنا الى
جنوب قطاع غزه وبالتالي عمليه الاكتضاض
تزداد يوما بعد اخر في ظل اوضاع صعبه نحن
في فصل الشتاء والناس فعلا بكل ما تحمل
الكلمه من معنى لا يوجد لهم ماوى لا يوجد
مكان يذهب اليه ولا يوجد خيام لا يوجد
غذاء لا يوجد دواء لا يوجد مياه كل
بالاضافه ايضا الى ان البنيه التحتيه لا
يمكن ان تحتمل كل هذه الاعداد الكبيره لك
ان تتخيلي ان الوصول الى عده مترات من في
هنا في مدينه رفح يمكن ان ياخذ اكثر من
ساعه المشي ربما حتى هناك ازدحام شديد حتى
من خلال المشي وبالتالي هي ايضا رفح معرضه
الى قصف اسرائيلي يوميا هناك غارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف في جلها اما شقق سكنيه
اما سيارات مدنيه وعشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى يوميا ينقلون الى المستشفيات
بالاضافه ايضا الى القصف المستمر لخان
يونس والاطراف الشماليه الشماليه الشرقيه
من رفح وهي المناطق التي تفصل ما بين رفح
وخانيونس وهي تتعرض الى قصف عنيف ولحظي
وهي ربما المحور الجديد الذي دخل منه
الجيش الاسرائيلي متوجها الى خانيونس
وبالتالي عمليات القصف مستمره ومتواصله
سواء كانت تلك المدفعيه او او حتى القنا
او حتى الغارات الجويه في خانيونس ربما
القصف اشد القصف هو الاعنف يستهدف منازل
مدنيه فلسطينيه يستهدف
ايضا المباني المرتفعه برج الفره مكون من
16 طابقا في خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه ودمرته
الطائرات الحربيه وسوته بالارض هو بالفعل
مخلى من السكان لان السكان نزحوا الى رفح
لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل عمليات
التدمير احياء باكملها في مخيم المغازي
ايضا دمرتها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
الطائرات الحديثه اكواد كابتر المسيره
تطلق النار في تلك المناطق في الوسط وفي
الجنوب في خانيونس على كل من يتحرك
وبالتالي السكان محاصرون في منازلهم في
منازلهم وبالتالي لا يستطيعون لا تقديم
اسعافات اوليه لاقاربهم او حتى جيرانهم
الذين يصابون في الشارع ولا حتى النزوح
والقدوم الى
رفح شكرا جزيلا لك هشام على هذه التفاصيل
ص